sonné ce merci anne bauer et médecins
spécialistes des expertises médicales
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
d'abord quelle est la situation en
allemagne que l'on a beaucoup cité comme
exemple heures en europe
et bien finalement elle n'est pas bien
différente des autres pays on a un des
compliments depuis lundi dernier dans
quinze jours ce qui n'est pas encore
très long et il faudra attendre les
résultats dans les jours qui viennent il
y a une limite de 50 niveaux cas par
jour
attili sur une population de 100 mille
habitants par le rayon par canton paris
ce qui est un peu discutable parce que
finalement quand vous l'avez dit tout
ailleurs l'explosion de deux cas sont
très restreints du mimi line particulier
un traitement de viande une maison de
retraite
évidemment dans une maison de retraite à
20k actuelle il n'est pas forcément
logique de remettre le confinement dans
tout le canton correspondant pour le
tourner dans ma tente
alors c'est vrai qu'à plusieurs cantons
à un canton tout cas qui est reparti en
en phase de confinement est ce qu'on
peut parler d'un début d'une deuxième
vague épidémique en allemagne selon vous
est ce qu'il ya des signes non non
écrite pour le plan géographique et
beaucoup de régions le connecter ou pas
de deux nouveaux cas ce qui est
évidemment en allemagne plus facile que
dans les autres pays grâce au général
évidemment c'est très différent pied
dans les rayons alors parlez nous un peu
de la stratégie de lutte contre la
pandémie en allemagne il ya eu beaucoup
de tests réalisés il ya beaucoup de
tests réalisés ils ont prouvé tout nous
encore plus on ne connaît toujours pas
le nombre de cas qui me sont restées
sans symptôme ou auprès de tantale
tonnes et donc on ne prenait pas le
nombre
malade de contact de personnes
contactées et et donc éviter d'être
interprétées et éthiques
c'est un problème que tout le monde
connaît la corse est un problème
généralisé un peu partout selon vous est
ce que les pouvoirs publics allemands
ont bien géré cette crise sanitaire dans
la mesure du possible lui les résultats
sont assez convaincants
maintenant il faut bien voir la vérité
république fédérale et les décisions
sont prises de façon rationnelle à
l'intérieur qui vend les communes par
exemple et vous avez des craintes vous
sur l'évolution à venir de l'épidémie
non je crois le problème des tantièmes
devient de plus en plus le problème des
conséquences économiques
et sur ce dernier point là est-ce que
selon vous l'allemagne a pris les bonnes
décisions
pratiquement les mêmes des filion que
d'autres c'est pas très différente
évidemment il faut ouvrir on ne peut pas
fermer grand père mais tout un pays
pendant plusieurs mois et d'un possible
s'agissant du des continents en
allemagne est ce que tout le monde porte
un masque comment ça se passe les
masques sont suffisants il est l'image
de son client il comporte et les marques
quand on va dans un magasin quand on va
acheter quant aux bas dans les
transports publics
il ne faut pas porter de masque que
quand on est à l'air libre et la plupart
des gens respectent ces règlementations
quand ils vont dans un magasin et
magasins sont limités c'est à dire pas
plus d'une ou deux personnes dans les
petits magasins dans les grands magasins
et le nombre de clients est également
réduit ses territoires attendre devant
la porte
le temps est beau donc c'est facile à
faire et vous savez que chez nous
vade confinés lundi quel conseil
pourriez donner aux français
finalement les français ne faut pas
qu'il ya autre chose que les allemands
il faut attendre il faut avoir confiance
pour regarder l'état des tic et des gars
pour le décider en conséquence
merci beaucoup à vous rené sebastian va
avoir je rappelle que vous êtes un
médecin à munich
merci à vous